[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir des enfants beaux soient pas
trop nos petits amis vont être contents
ce soir je vais le raconter une jolie
histoire de philippines et du lapin
blanc non une autre une nouvelle
je descend vite mon échelle vo hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop on
lire samedi pepita oui c'est lui c'est
mars exactement le voilà votre nounours
mais oui c'est moi ou le broad et sans
le superbe
mes amis ce soir je vais vous raconter
une belle histoire qu'elle sera une des
celle que tu racontes à nicolas et
pimprenelle non une nouvelle
c'est l'histoire d'un petit garçon
une enfant puisse y est
racontée vite chers amis une seconde je
me pose là écoutez bien
dans une petite île fait de sable de
coquillages est devant
viva un marin pêcheur breton il était
tout ça non ce marin pêcheur breton
avait un bateau une maison qu'il avait
construite ni mal une femme et un petit
garçon comment s'appelle-t-il fille jade
si jenny continuer mon cher nos sources
cette histoire m'intéresse merci dada
tous les soirs le papa de gan posait
dans la mer de grands filets et tous les
matins au lever du jour il est relevé qu
est ce qu ils attrapaient toutes sortes
de poissons et de crustacés
des langoustines des crabes des homards
et langoustes et des araignées de mer
qui est oui sans itt remontait sardines
des reins des rongeurs et beaucoup d'eau
à c'est un métier qui m'aurait plu à moi
woerth a pas pu il allait ensuite au
port rendre sa pêche puis il rentrait
chez lui à l'air marin nada mais un
matin alors qu'il tirait ses fils un
tram à l'habitude il entendit
qu'est ce que c'était il vit au milieu
de tout ça ta vie un petit phoque
ou
que un phoque qui parlait je vais le
vendre ce ni le marin pêcheur breton
mais je vais d'abord le montrer à mon
petit garçon mon dieu qu'est ce qu'il a
dit le petit yann lou lou lou s'écria
yann en saisissant le phoque par le cou
ou
lui répondit le petit foc en frottant
son museau moustachu contre l'ajout du
petit garçon
se dit le marin pêcheur breton
je ne vendrai pas se fera qu aujourd'hui
puisqu'il joue avec mon fiston avait un
lien et d'autres marins pêcheurs bretons
avaient maintenant un bateau une maison
une femme un petit garçon et un phoque
et voilà les enfants l'histoire est
terminée
elle vous a plu oh oui nous met une
rencontre adam dit oui j'aime tellement
les histoires mois ce produit mes amis
et je vous laisse de lille
merci céramique comme sow
bonne nuit la roulotte opening nous tous
mes voeux vous accompagne
[Musique]
bravo nounours elle était très jolie
dont histoire n'est-ce pas mais j'en
connais d'autres patrons beaucoup
d'autres et je les raconte si bien vous
ne trouvez pas oui une hausse et bien je
vous raconterai avoue aussi pour vous
endormir
c'est inutile 90 j'ai tout ce qu'il me
faut pour cela que je suis bête
pardon monsieur le marchand de sable
alors en route
bonne nuit les enfants
que je suis bonne
fêtes de bourg
[Musique]
et
oh